según los corredores de apuestas son 8
los favoritos destacan 2022 derrotados
en la final de la pasada edición los
senegaleses siguen en la búsqueda de su
primer trofeo continental guiados por
saudí omán el balón de oro africano en
2019 los leones de la teranga y su
seleccionador a liu si se recibieron la
bandera nacional en el palacio
presidencial ocasión perfecta para que
el mandatario en maquillar subiera la
presión
serkán destacan es el momento de la
verdad para el fútbol senegalés
como
un momento crucial en el que se debe
hacer una exigencia de victoria
defensora del título la argelia de jamel
vell marí llega plena de confianza
camerún puede apoyarse en una serie
inédita para un equipo africano 34
partidos consecutivos sin derrota para
los zorros del desierto conducidos por
su capitán el jugador creativo del
manchester city read mar es el país con
más títulos en su palmarés siete copas
africanas egipto también tendrá algo que
decir mejor goleador y líder de
asistencias de la premier league con
liverpool mohamed salah camina sobre el
agua desde el comienzo de la campaña él
tratará de ganar la primera copa
africana para su país desde 2010 detrás
del trío de favoritos varios outsiders
comenzando por costa de marfil los
elefantes que cuentan en sus filas con
sebastián ale diez goles en sólo seis
partidos en la liga de campeones esta
temporada
nos olvidemos tampoco de nigeria y
camerún el país se de consagrado en 2017
que querrá ante su público hacer que la
copa se quede en casa